well from the standpoint of food
producers and food companies the United
States the most important issue is price
or has been price keep the price as low
as possible so that has led to a
consolidation of food production in a
way that has driven out small farmers so
that through economies of scale food
prices are kept low it also has allowed
food corporations to outsource the
production of food I once heard an
official at the Department of
Agriculture's say that he didn't think
we should be growing fruit in America at
all we should be outsourcing all of it
and using our land for recreation and
housing I thought that was really
interesting so much for homeland
security though and so we live in it we
live in a global world we get an
enormous amount of our food and food
ingredients from countries like China
that don't have the same kind of safety
standards that we do we need to work on
that and we are working
you